the Trump administration is now making
allegations and threats against a
dangerous foreign government and that
government is Syria military and
intelligence officials however are
saying we've got no clue what the hell
the White House is talking about the
White House said in a statement on
Monday night that it believes the Syrian
regime is planning another one of these
chemical weapons attacks on rebel
civilians the White House put out a
statement saying quote the United States
has identified potential preparations
for another chemical weapons attack by
the Assad regime that would likely
result in the mass murder of civilians
including innocent children so basically
what they're saying is we are seeing
Syria do things similarly to what we
observed before that April 4th sarin gas
attack which killed dozens of civilians
in which cause Donald Trump's have sent
cruise missiles to a Syrian air base so
they say it's been abnormal activity at
an air base where we suspect Syria is
storing chemical weapons and they went
on to say in this exact same statement
quote if mr. Assad conduct another mass
murder attack using chemical weapons he
and his military will pay a heavy price
the White House was asked about what are
you talking about here or what kind of
action would Donald Trump take if there
were to be another chemical weapons
attack in Syria we haven't gotten
answers there and here is where it gets
totally whacked pat several sources at
the Pentagon the CIA and the State
Department were asked about this why did
the White House issue this threat and
they say we have no idea we don't know
why the White House issued this threat
against Syria and why they said we
believe they believe that there may be
another chemical attack coming in fact
one official at US Central Command said
the BuzzFeed that he has quote no idea
what the White House is talking about
several State Department officials say
that they first learned about the
possibility of Syria planning a chemical
attack when they read about it in the
newspaper based on the White House's
statement this came three days after the
state the Defense Department
started talking publicly about wanting
to relieve tensions with the Syrian
government in order to try to team up
against Isis in the region I'm guessing
that's not going to be helped by this
release from the White House
no and the idea of making a threat isn't
necessarily a terrible one because you
might as well stop the chemical attacks
from happening if you can rather than
having to deal with the repercussions
and perhaps you know attacking them if
need be the problem that you run into if
you're not on the same page is maybe you
run into the same thing that Obama dealt
with with that redline and yes and
certain and you have this obligation to
commit to that redline and enforce what
you said in the first place and of
course that would bring up issues of
whether Donald Trump has the
authorization to use military force in
that case because that that anti
al-qaeda AUMF certainly is running
ragged at this point as a justification
and there's really two possible
scenarios of what's going on here and
neither neither scenario is really good
okay so number one these might be
serious allegations that the
administration is making against Syria
they might be based in fact and the
Pentagon and others are saying we don't
know what they're talking about because
once again Donald Trump in the White
House may have spilled what is supposed
to be secret classified information
imagine that we did have this
intelligence which suggested you know
what Syria might be about to do this and
Donald Trump and the White House weren't
supposed to go public with that that's
one reason why when you go to the
Pentagon they might say but no idea
what's going on no idea what's going on
whatsoever and that yet again would be
incredibly dangerous if once again the
Trump administration is jeopardizing
national security by talking about stuff
that's supposed to be secret and
classified the other possibility pad is
that the White House is making it up
right that the White House decided to
completely conjure this out of thin air
merely to threaten a foreign country
saber-rattling to distract from the
endless scandals of the Trump
administration that would also explain
why the Pentagon would say why do we
have no idea what you're talking about
it just sounds like the latest chapter
of Trump either disrespecting the
intelligence community and or
inappropriately revealing classified
information and it sounds very
unbecoming of someone who criticized
Hillary Clinton for doing the exact same
thing
absolutely and this could be the big
picture here is maybe the administration
wants to distract from everything that's
going on with the healthcare disaster
who's talking about the tax plan anymore
that's dead in the water
Mexican wall that Mexico will pay for I
mean that hasn't been brought up in
months at this point countless other
scandals Trump Russia etc a little saber
rattling maybe some headlines about
Trump threatened Syria's not the worst
thing in the world form at this point
approval ratings in the tank but you
know it seems to fluctuate between 35 to
40 percent yeah you know stepping up
perhaps a war in Syria help them get
beyond that ceiling maybe I mean I don't
think at this point that it would hurt
especially or he can make a credible
case even if it's not based in evidence
or if it's based in evidence that
shouldn't be public and shows he
mishandled classified information
it might help his approval rating I
don't know bottom line though whether
it's true or not right whether it's
actually true that Syria maybe in
preparations for another one of these
chemical gas attacks talking publicly
about it is some combination of saber
rattling for approval ratings combined
with attempts to distract from all of
the bad things that are going on
including as I mentioned at the top of
the show yet another embarrassing
failure of the health care bill we
cannot understate for a second the level
of embarrassment that Republicans should
feel after years of talking about
repealing and replacing Obamacare that
they still can't put together a plan
that even Republicans can agree on
never mind bringing on any Democratic
support so I would not put it past the
white house to try to distract from that
and rattle Sabres by saying you'd better
not Syria we know what you're doing and
we're not going to let you send me your
thoughts about this where are you on
this issue I'm on Twitter at D Pakman I
encourage you I ask you sincerely and
humbly to follow me there you can also
follow the david pakman show on twitter
at david pakman show we'll be back after
this